well certainly what define a great dish
is your own taste to start with and your
own palate and you how discernible you
are and now you like that type of dishes
you know Aang gradient or maybe the most
important part of a dish for me too much
has been said about Chef knowing that
has been said about former to grow the
line gradient because we are absolutely
nothing without the farmer you know and
he doesn't get the credit for it so if
you have extraordinary ingredient and if
you don't mess it up by doing too much
with it or other cooking and all that if
you are pretty calm about it and then
you probably will have a great dish I
mean it can be just an extraordinary
tomato at the right time pressure with
the best possible oil best possible
onion with it and that's what we look
for you know when very often people
think in terms of great dish in the
context of complicated dish when in fact
I often discussed with the young chef
and I said okay I would test you by
doing a lobster roll maybe a hamburger
maybe a hot dog maybe a BLT any of those
which are very very modern and very
simple you can already have a very
bright a better master a better piece of
meat a bit of way of cooking it you can
always work in depth rather than
otherwise and get something better and
you do I have a place next to in
Connecticut where I go and have lobster
roll what I have in front of my account
road with my dearest friend and was with
me when I work with French president so
we've been cooking together a 51-year
he'll come and say let's go have a
lobster roll you remember that lobster
roll weather guy take those Philadelphia
flat role that we started at Howard
Johnson actually when I live there and
brown them on each side properly and
that's just plan a lobster that he
pushed himself or steam himself with
Burrell tubs all paper and put it and
that's it but it's good quality so you
remember it and you go back to it
in my kid will probably remember the
catastrophe that you have a great
success that you are and otherwise you
know one goes into the other there is
never a dish which is absolutely perfect
you know there it can earn some time you
get close enough that you're very
satisfied with yourself but again it has
to do with your own palate without any
question if you decide on the 10 best
restaurant in New York or the 10 best
restaurant in front and if I go to those
10 restaurant five maybe five six of
them I'm going to think are absolutely
extraordinary two or three of them I'm
going to sing their up quite good and a
couple of them I'm going to say I don't
understand why those people are three
star and what I'm saying there is that
you cannot escape yourself so the four
or five that I absolutely adore just
happened to coincide exactly with my
sense of taste with my sense of
aesthetic so it's purely a narcissistic
reflection if you want on my own taste
because that coincide with what I like
and the other one I'm not as familiar
with it so and I said to a certain
extent you can work with many from
people but you cannot escape yourself at
some point you are who you are and that
will be expressed in the food that's
what I try to tell the student at BU for
example i have a class of 10 12 student
hands on and i do a class of two hours i
say i'm going to do the perfect meal for
you today a roast chicken a boiled
potato and a salad it has to be done
exactly the right way basting the right
way the salad has to be cleaned out the
right way so at the right temperature
with the right dressing the right oil
with the right amount right temperature
the potato has to be done this way and
so forth fine so they do that they
tested then they go to the stove and do
it now they have two hours to duplicate
my dish my my three dish and I always
said don't try to be original don't try
to up do one another to don't try to be
different than so what else because you
are different and whether you like on
that for the better or for the worse I
am going to have 10 different chicken a
couple of them practically perfect a
couple
all that couple undercooked a couple
undercooked echo but whatever they will
be different because you are different
and you cannot escape yourself so you
don't have to torture yourself to sign
that dish to make sure that people know
you've done it because it will be
different based way